it's great to be joined today by Bruce
Schneier who is a fellow at the Harvard
Kennedy School Bruce later on in today's
program we're going to talk about the
recent revelations regarding yahoo and
email but you recently commented on
other corporate denial statements other
companies rushing to say oh oh we're
absolutely not doing that and I think to
summarize your view on some of those
denials is is skeptical an
understatement you seem to think that
this is more common than what we've
heard so far is that right it probably
is certainly we know that the NSA
collapse corporate surveillance
regularly sometimes they use court
orders what seems to be in the yahoo
case sometimes they just steal the data
we know that happened with Google and
their overseas data centers sometimes
they will buy it sometimes they will use
threats and when you read some of these
corporate denials they tend to be very
carefully worded and always look at the
wording and the parsing because my guess
is this is much more prevalent then a
particular news story and we just hear
little bits and pieces of what's a very
pervasive surveillance program you've
spoken about pretty extensively this
idea that you actually gave a TED talk
called the security Mirage where you
talk about security trade-offs and very
often when we hear a story like we do
about oh uh authorities agencies were
reading people's email even before they
read the email for example very often
the average sort of person will think
about it in terms of does this sort of
feel like I'm getting more security
relative to how much privacy i'm losing
what's the sort of fundamental problem
with thinking about these news stories
and these surveillance techniques sort
of in this amorphous does it feel like a
good trade-off method what's wrong with
that a trade offs probably a good way to
think about it but not security versus
privacy its security versus security so
we know that pervasive surveillance by
government
make citizens insecure I mean that's why
we don't all move to China or didn't all
move to East Germany or former Iraq that
government surveillance is toxic for
governments to do and is toxic for
populations to be subjected to which is
why when we built the United States
Constitution we put in very strong rules
about police surveillance and now it had
to be tailored and targeted and minimal
and necessary these programs fly in the
face of that and that makes us less
secure we're not saying that the FBI the
NSA shouldn't conduct surveillance it's
that broad surveillance of populations
is bad for our security and on top of
that it doesn't actually give us
security against criminals and
terrorists and all those other things
that sort of another half of it this is
really the way to look at it and
unfortunately this is hard because when
people are scared they willing to say do
whatever it takes to make me feel less
scared even though it might be
ineffective you know it might be
corrosive people going to go along with
it I'm going to get into the details
later in the program about some of the
past finds that Yahoo was was a victim
of with regard to not participating in
prism but can you talk to us a little
generally from your knowledge what are
some of the ways or maybe a better way
to say it is how prevalent is it that
government agencies will try to
strong-arm some of these big tech
companies that have a lot of data into
playing ball with them either in terms
of data turnover or back doors etc how
does that function in the real world you
know we don't know a lot of details we
just see snippets of it so we know in
one case the NSA bribed RSA to put it
back door one of their encryption
systems so we know that we know that a
lot comes from legal compulsion we saw
the verizon order that was one of the
Snowden documents now we're seeing this
Yahoo demand we see bits from different
companies transparency reports my guess
is that when you had them are
traditional companies the telcos there
was a tradition
playing along so we know that the NSA
put Massa be dropping equipment in AT&T
s data centers around the country and
they did that by asking nicely but 18t
had a history of cooperating with the
NSA throughout the Cold War so this was
an easy thing to do when they did the
same thing to becoming like Google will
probably said go away we're not going to
do that which is why they had to resort
to other mechanisms so I think there's a
lot of culture between the telco culture
and the Silicon Valley culture and the
differences and it's a lot about
relationships now you want to help if
you're approached by the US government
and then told there's an attack imminent
please help keep America safe it's hard
to say no but it shouldn't be hard to
say get a warrant it shouldn't be hard
to say go before a judge follow the law
and then we will help you seal up would
you feel differently about a lot of this
if instead of knowing that particularly
the bulk surveillance that was exposed
by the Snowden leaks and subsequently by
the initially incorrect statements of
the NSA regarding how effective this
type of surveillance is would you feel
differently broadly speaking about this
type of surveillance if we found out it
really was effective at preventing real
real-life violence terrorist attacks etc
the Fourth Amendment's always about
trade-offs and we'd have to look at that
and if it turned out that these tools
were extraordinarily effective we would
have to look at the cost look at the
benefits and make a trade off if you
think about it we already give the
police extraordinary power to peer into
a personalized why because we know it
solves crimes we know it keeps us safe
we just have mechanisms around that to
ensure the police don't abuse their
authority and more or less they work so
it really isn't absolute it's about
figuring out what the limits are and
figuring out how to give authorities
these capabilities without losing our
liberties without losing our freedoms
and we can do that we've done that in
the past we
do in the future but we have to have the
facts to make these decisions as a
society I'd like to talk a little bit
with you about computer security in the
context of the upcoming election and
every election there are observed broad
range of different concerns and
allegations that crop up regarding often
the tampering of voting machines Donald
Trump has been more frequently using the
term rig than whether it applies
exclusively to voting machines it
appears the answer is no but that may be
part of it up from a computer security
perspective when we think about a
national election which is really 50
individual state elections often managed
in in pretty drastically different ways
what are the concerns that everybody
should sort of generally be aware of
when it comes to computer security I
think about the election security there
are three areas that I worry about yeah
the first one is a reservation system
that a lot of havoc can be raped by
deleting or changing voter rolls people
try to vote and they can't because
they're not on the system there have
been probes in several states there have
been tests a lot of shoddy security
there the second is election machines
themselves a lot of them are vulnerable
to hacking some of them in key states
especially the ones that are touchscreen
only without paper audit trails and the
third is the tabulation and
dissemination that after we vote those
totals are sent up the chain and
aggregated and there's a lot of room for
attacks there so looking at those three
steps those are the vulnerabilities and
I think we need to really apply some
technology here it's a bit late for this
election you have to really pay
attention and use humans to try to
secure our system but I worry i worry
about Russian involvement I worry about
kids playing politics hmm i think these
offer important concerns lesson the
presidential election more in local
elections where little changes can make
a big difference but i think we start
have to worry about our election system
and whether it is critical national
infrastructure in the same way our power
grid is and i think you can make a case
that it is from a purely sort of
logistical and technical standpoint of
the three areas of concern that you
mentioned which would be the easiest for
sort of a lone wolf to affect and which
might be more on the spectrum of
requiring a coordinated effort you know
pretty much everything can be done by a
lone wolf I mean this is the thing about
computer security it doesn't require a
nation state to do it it could be two
guys in the basement somewhere so that
really isn't the the factor what really
matters is whether it will be effective
you know and if you think about it if
you wanted to swing the US presidential
election it's not easy you're not going
to know where the hinge points will be
you can't do a lot of swinging because
you know it'll be noticed more worrisome
or local elections state elections city
elections county elections where there
are much fewer eyes on it where the
stakes are smaller where there's more
petty infighting I worry they're more if
you think what's happening about this
election we're seeing Russia do kind of
a disinformation campaign which really
isn't attacking the election but
attacking the information process
leading up to the election and that's
something that a nation-state might do
you know we talk a lot about election
vulnerabilities and they're serious
pulling it off as stole a lot of luck
and a lot of skill and I think that's in
our favor but we really should secure
our systems because we don't have a
process if there's a problem I mean we
don't have a system to vote over a week
later right to fix it if the we open up
the machines and the votes are old 00 we
just don't know what to do and after an
election there are sides now we can
discuss what to do and nobody cares the
day after election day half of the
country is going to say fix it other
half is going to say don't fix it it's
fine right it'll become partisan so
whatever we do we have to do now before
we know the results no doubt about that
we've been speaking with Bruce Schneier
he is a fellow at the Harvard Kennedy
School really a pleasure speaking with
you thank you so much thank you